The fury of the countryside is felt today throughout Spain,
from south to north,
from east to west.
of farmers protest at 1 Negro
on the roads.
Most of these
eh mobilizations
had not been officially convened.
Livestock farmers and farmers have organized
almost almost on the fly.
Through or on social networks
raise their voices
to demand that their products be defended
compared to those arriving
from outside the European Union.
Another big headline of the morning
comes to us from the Supreme Court
because the board of prosecutors has ruled in favor of the judge
García Castellón
and endorses by 1 large majority
that Karlaspus Demon be investigated for terrorism.
This can greatly complicate the government's plans
on amnesty.
The British are in shock today
for the news of Charles of England's cancer.
The King has suspended his public agenda
and is already receiving treatment.
His son Harry,
with whom he had had problems lately,
has just arrived in London.
This other image is an impact.
See how the interior of this building has turned out
5-story building that has collapsed
in Badalona.
The building collapsed from the third floor
and everything fell apart